This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black. people listen to look back at it on the iHeart radio app apple podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences having honest conversations
that's really not safe to have anywhere but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing how many men carry a suit or armor it signals to the world that you not to be played with and just because you have the capabilities you have the capabilities that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Ranchini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s. and what they mean for our psychology.
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, thank you for tuning in for another topic. So something that I've been contemplating a lot recently is those periods in our lives, kind of those moments, sometimes those seasons where life just seems to lose a lot of. of its color and it becomes quite bland and stale. Nothing quite feels as exciting as it used to. Everything feels very monotonous and just kind of boring. Life feels really boring and devoid of those experiences and emotions that keep us excited, kind of lacking that sense of a future that there's something to be looking forward to or excited about. And
I think it's a pretty hideous feeling, as I'm speaking from my own experience, to look around and realize that your life has kind of become something that you never wanted it to be, to recognize that you are just bored. You are bored of your own life. And I don't think that boredom is something we need to be afraid of. But when it becomes the dominant emotion and you're in this constant state where nothing ever changes, I think it's really hard to look at your life as, if there is a certain meaning to it or to just be happy and content with the way you are going
about things. I had this when I first started working my 9 to 5 and my days were just consumed by waking up, commuting to work, eating the same lunch, the same breakfast each day, leaving at 7pm and then just being too exhausted to even do anything afterwards but watch TV and I repeated this routine week after week for almost a year. And it was honestly so soul destroying. And I just kept remembering this promise that I made to myself when I was younger that I would never have an office job, that I would make my life as exciting as it could be. And it really hurt to realize that I was failing that younger version of myself that really wanted something more on top of that kind of chronic boredom that was seeping into all other areas of my life.
and you know, work and the full-time corporate grind are not the only corporate here. I think it's an accumulation of a lot of factors that push us into these extreme moments of just kind of emptiness. And I know that was such a pessimistic intro. I'm very sorry. But if that is you right now, if you've lost a bit of your passion and spirit, the older you've gotten as you've kind of hit some of those less fun responsibilities of adulthood, and your early 20s.
This episode is for you. This episode will hopefully provide you with two things. Firstly, a psychological explanation for why that is. Why does life feel boring? Pointing to a lot of external factors but also internal ones. I think that to know the problem is to fix the problem or at least understand it better. And so secondly, what are we going to do about it? You really do deserve a life that you actually enjoy, not one where kind of time feels like
it's standing still and you're just kind of sleep walking through your days. I feel like it's quite cliche to say this, but I think sometimes we just need a reminder that you truly only get one life. You know, I have to really hold back from the saying yolo there, but, you know, it's kind of cringed to say, but really on a somewhat serious note, this is it. you are not going to get this time back. And I think a lot of us, myself included, sometimes go through periods of perhaps living as if this life is a practice round, that we can do it differently next time. And sadly, based on your beliefs, but based on my beliefs, there is no next time. You really do owe
yourself the full depth of human experiences and to break out of this boredom cycle. So let's talk about how we can do this. Before we jump into the advice, let's firstly talk about the human experience of boredom. We have a tendency to villainize certain emotions as bad or to be avoided, but each of them plays their role, I guess, boredom included. And boredom is essentially your brain, telling you that something needs to change. The same way that hunger tells our body to fuel itself or loneliness tells us to reconnect. Bortem is our brains signal to our body that our current
situation or environment is not providing us enough engagement or meaning and it's somewhat, you know, draining our innate spirit. And I know that's not a psychology term, but kind of, I think it explains how it feels. And it typically occurs when our energy isn't channeled into an outlet that feels personally meaningful to us, like a dead-end job or a failing relationship. There's an important distinction here between what psychologists call trait boredom and state boredom. So trait boredom is how susceptible we are as individuals to feeling dissatisfied and understimulated by our environment and relationships, regardless of what is actually going on. And the theory behind this concept is that there are certain people who are high in trait bored that may feel bored even in situations that
objectively are really exciting, like during while they're traveling or during big life events. Basically, their threshold for mental stimulation is so high that the events that would excite them would make them entertained and happy have to be so intense that they are almost cursed by chronic boredom. It may also come, I guess, from an inability to sustain our attention, which is fairly typical amongst people with ADHD who often find themselves becoming quite bored with things very quickly, not from a place of personal fault, but because their brains literally cannot keep them stimulated and excited by something for an extended period of time. We might say that they have high trait boredom in the situation and people with this high trait boredom, they are more likely
to take exaggerated or really intensive risks, they're more likely to experience anxiety, depression and even substance abuse at extreme levels. And I think that makes a lot of sense from a logical standpoint, if the rest of the world cannot give you the enjoyment that you need, maybe turning to artificial enhancers like drugs or alcohol is kind of the only viable solution in that moment. Luckily for us, the vast majority of people do not have high trait boredom. You and me, the average person, we are more likely to experience what is known as state boredom. So this is when we feel bored in a specific situation based on, our current environment and basically the theory suggests that boredom in these instances
arises as a product of what we call situational meaninglessness. We look at what we're doing and we cannot find the why behind why we're doing it. You know, sitting in a class where you're not learning anything particularly relevant or in some eight hour seminar for a job you don't love. Being in that situation feels like it lacks purpose for the plans that you have for your life. And this essentially cues boredom, triggers boredom, which is telling our brain that something needs to change. So in those moments, it's a combination of low mental arousal and feeling unpleasant, and we want to avoid that. So our brain is saying, this is not making me happy. I don't want to be here. This is not fun for me. And not only is it not fun,
but it's not particularly aligned with what we kind of had in mind for our lives. It's this phenomenon known as chronic dissatisfaction, that restless feeling of yearning or wishing for something more without even knowing what it is, but knowing that we are not happy. When this occurs, when life just feels really boring and we feel trapped by our current circumstances, this can actually operate as what we would call a catalyst for change. So it's kind of this symbolic kick to get us going, to get us back on the horse, to reclaim the agency we have over our lives and decisions.
And that's probably the state that you are in right now if you are here listening to this episode. You may have ignored some of those initial cues for too long or begun to feel overwhelmingly comfortable, which is a nice enough feeling, but the reality of human existence is that our brains need a certain level of cognitive stimulation not only to grow but to keep us happy. Our brains also need a challenge or something to work towards, otherwise they become static. And in that state we use these same neural pathways over and over again. We do the same things. We are not pushing our brain to engage in what we would call synaptic or neuroplasticity, whereby we strengthen and weaken certain synaptic
pathways, depending on what our environment requires. So when we don't provide ourselves with new experiences, our brains become less alert, they become less engaged, they become less curious, and that results in that sense of flatness. And even in some cases, like we spoke about before, kind of a reliance on external pleasures, substances to keep us happy. And there was a very famous study that has showed this correlation, this relationship, using rats. This experiment conducted in the 1970s, it was called Rat Park, which is, first of all, just a super cute name to start off with. But essentially, these researchers, they created three different homes or environment.
for these little rats and one was full of enrichment it had toys and slides and other rats they could play with and the next condition had other rats but less enrichment and the final setting involved just one rat alone in a cage by itself with nothing to entertain it the experimenters then gave the rats two water bottles two kind of sources of hydration one of the water bottles just contained water, and the other one was water laced with cocaine and heroin. The rats who had enrichment, and they had their little rat friends to play with, they didn't really go for the cocaine water. It was like free drugs and they just were not interested. They were happy with just plain water. But the rats who were alone and who were bored and who had nothing to
entertain themselves exclusively drank the cocaine water to the point that they became ill. and even died despite having the plain water available. And basically what this study concluded is that our drive to avoid boredom is so strong that we will go as far as to perhaps harm ourselves with things like alcohol, substances, junk food, just to give us a little bit of enrichment. We need to be challenged. We need to be entertained more than we need a lot of other things. And so our brain is going to respond in a few ways, not just regarding substance usage, but other ways when it feels this impending sense of boredom. The first is triggering that deep dissatisfaction we've spoken about because it hopes that that will trigger certain behavioral decisions as a way to avoid these feelings, like changing something about our environment, putting ourselves out there, doing more quote unquote fun things so that we achieve. that emotional kind of equilibrium homeostasis. But the second interaction which we've spoken about
briefly is really interesting. So according to the study published in the Cognition and Emotion Journal in 2021, experiencing prolonged state boredom actually results in what we would call an optimistic perception of risk, an increased risk-taking behavior. So as this article explains, the evolutionary function of boredom is to motivate us to pursue an alternative experience. And sometimes we swing way too far in the opposite direction to compensate for feeling so shitty and so stuck for so long. So they found that participants in this study who self-reported that they were currently quite bored in their lives, they took a lot more risks. It's why we find ourselves when we are feeling this way, wanting to spontaneously change
our hair or book some elaborate holiday or get a tattoo or break up with our partners. Our brains are just trying to recalibrate in that moment. But that doesn't always leave us in the most sustainable position. You know, you just have a new hair color or a new tattoo, not a new outlook. So it's a temporary fix for what is a deeper emotional and mental issue, not feeling able to direct your efforts to the things in life that will keep you fulfilled and happy. Perhaps, you know, you've been spending too much time in your routine or there are certain environmental triggers like those behind seasonal effective disorder.
There are a lot of reasons, but also a lot of ways that we can counteract that. So if you are someone who is feeling like life is just incredibly boring right now, I want to provide you with some tips to get over that, some tips to feel better about the kind of miracle and beauty of life. We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience. in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers,
and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends, I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends.
Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio Hour, Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack.
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important
to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing,
growth, fatherhood, pressure, purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app, search Learn the Hardway, and listen now. Just because life feels boring doesn't mean that it's always going to be that way. It's worth noting that we are all going to experience the occasional moment or period of dissatisfaction, especially since I don't think any one thing, a job, a hobby, a holiday, a partner can keep us happy forever. And so we need boredom to kind of tell us when it's time to change, when it's time to keep evolving. And if we listen to that boredom, if we don't let it suffocate us,
but motivate us, I also think that it can be quite transformative. So I want to talk about some of the key factors that cause life to feel boring, but also what exactly we can do about it to kind of counterbalance or counteract their influence. Firstly, Being so stuck in our routine that we don't have any new or novel experiences is a massive contributor. Routine is great for creating structure, reducing stress, allowing us to do the things we want and need to do. But when it is too highly stringent, it can actually confine our lives. It leaves little room or possibility for spontaneity. We've spoken about this before on the podcast, the benefit of the way.
of what we call an anti-routine. The premise is that you actually need to give yourself time to do things that are unexpected and to expose yourself to new experiences. You cannot plan out every single moment of your life, every single moment of your day. It might make you feel like you have more control, but it could also be contributing to some deeper emotional experiences.
If life is feeling boring, break out of your routine for a moment and try and just do one new unexpected thing a week. Whether that is trying a new gym class or a new restaurant, just starting a new project, literally just eating something new or listening to different music or a different podcast, all of those things provides our brain with the novelty that it needs to feel less bored. And research into brain health, cognition, longevity. it suggests that regular experiences of novelty, like the ones we've just spoken about, are essential to a long, happy life, but also for reducing that boredom, that sense of being stuck.
Here's the psychology behind this theory. Our brains need stimulation and new experiences, and the reason for this preference is really simple. Novelty makes us happy. It just makes us happy. And brain research has shown that we get such a rush, of dopamine. Every time we see something new, we experiencing something new of any kind. They published this study in this journal called Neuron, and in this study, they showed participants a series of images that were mostly very basic, simple, commonplace, things like, you know,
ordinary landscapes, like a field, a couch, basic faces, like very boring, simple images. And then they randomly threw in like an oddball image, something that was really unexpected, really out of the ordinary. And what they did was they watched their brain activity to see what areas of the brain was activated when they saw these oddball images. And what they found was that the pleasure centres of the brain, mainly located in the midbrain, were activated extremely more so when the participants saw this. like new fresh image compared to when they just were staring at the basic ordinary landscapes. What this is telling us is that when we restrict ourselves to the ordinary and constant routine and structure, we receive less of that dopamine and excitement. So you need to push beyond your comfort zone every now and again, book the trip, do something
spontaneous, shake things up a bit, embrace the anti-routine and you'll feel a lot better. Secondly, another reason we can feel bored by life is kind of counterintuitive and it's because of overstimulation and excessive social media usage. Now, this occurs because of two reasons. Firstly, when we consume so much social media, we spend so much of our lives online, our brains can no longer focus its attention onto just one thing. Secondly, it's the impact of social comparison. Let's start with the first one. there have been an abundance of research papers in recent years into the impact of fast media, particularly social media, on our ability to get genuine enjoyment from life.
Our brains were not built for receiving this much information. And nowadays, they have been completely exposed to this whole new way of receiving information and receiving messages from the world around us. And so they have almost been altered by the instant gratification created by 30 second, 10 second videos and TikToks and videos and online content with flashing lights that are going to immediately give our brain a bit of a dopamine hit. Nowadays, we can find ourselves sitting on the couch, aimlessly scrolling for what could be hours, rather than actually engaging in our environment.
and in our lives. And as one article put it, a lot of our experience with the internet is based on, as we said before, instant gratification. And as a result, our attention span is shortening and we are used to receiving that spike of dopamine instantly from our phones. That makes the rest of our lives where we might not get that stimulation right away, where it's just a little bit less colorful because it's not artificial. It feels boring. And additionally, being able to sustain our attention also is important so that not being something that we can do as well as we used to be able to that's going to increase boredom levels because it means that we can no longer actually focus on pursuing our ideas our goals and our visions for our lives
because we get distracted so easily and that is the first explanation the second has to do a social comparison. Here is the fallacy of platforms like Instagram. They will convince you that everyone is doing better than you, is happier than you, is having the fucking time of their life, and you might see that and it's going to completely change your appraisal, your perspective on your own happiness levels if you're not careful. Not everyone can travel Europe for their entire lives, or is constantly having the experiences that you might wish you were having. And when we don't have that oversight, that reality check, it can make it feel like our lives are comparatively quite boring, even if we have every reason to be super happy. Here's how we can break away from that
infiltration that is making you feel like your life lacks some color or some meaning. Firstly, go and search of some real dopamine here. Something that is, exist beyond the screen, beyond the instant gratification of social media, or better yet, kind of challenge yourself to a dopamine detox to offer a bit of a circuit break or an opportunity to rewire your attention and how your brain processes enjoyment. So a dopamine detox entails essentially fasting or giving up certain dopamine producing activities like social media, junk food, things like that, anything that's a pleasure with the hope of decreasing your reward sensitivity. So the idea is that by allowing ourselves to feel bored or to
feel lonely, we find pleasure more so in very simple and more natural activities. And that allows us to regain control over our lives and be better able to address certain, compulsive behaviors that might be interfering with our happiness. Now, I will say there hasn't been much research into the long-term efficacy of this practice, but some people really celebrate it anecdotally as it being the thing that got them to stop wasting their life consuming things like social media. And it made them feel a lot less unsatisfied with the overall state of their lives because they got to experience and spend more time actually enjoying those small joys, noticing the
mundane, kind of focusing on what it is that is their sense of purpose. Also, you know, as a bonus, detaching ourselves from social media also reduces a lot of those opportunities for social comparison and kind of allows us to put the version of our self forward that we actually like, not one that has been curated or altered or changed to fit some certain expectation. So the third reason life might feel quite boring is because of something more clinical, like depression or even seasonal effective disorder. Depression is a real possibility if you aren't just bored, but you do not find joy in anything that you do. In particular, the things that used to make you so happy and used to make you feel so alive. We did a whole episode on depression
and the links to feeling stagnant, but seasonal effective disorder, I think, is one that requires some special attention in this episode, especially as the winter months are coming in fast for a lot of you all in the northern hemisphere. So seasonal affective disorder or depression or the winter blues. It occurs when the days become shorter, the sun sets sooner, the cold kind of starts to creep in, and it naturally causes our mood to plummet. It kind of locks our social schedule and the amount of time we have to do things that really refresh the soul, like go outside, like actually see our friends, feel human. And it may explain why the sense that life as boring can be very seasonal. And really, you know, after the fun of the summer and the
spring months has faded, we can find ourselves kind of trapped in this sense of life feeling quite meaningless. My best advice is to make sure that you actually have things in the future to keep you excited about. That was like my main hack when I lived in Canberra where it got freezing cold and the sun was genuinely only up for eight hours. I kind of always made sure that there was something planned in the next two months, three months in the summer months that gave me something to actually look forward to. It was kind of a light at the end of the tunnel, a reminder that life is not boring, it is just cold, it is just freezing, I am just sad. And there will be more time to create those fun moments and experiences for myself. I want to talk about four final tips.
春天的月份已经渐远，我们会发现自己陷入了一种生活毫无意义的虚无感中。我给出的最好建议是，确保你的未来确实有一些能让你感到兴奋的事情。这就像是我住在堪培拉时的主意，那里冷得刺骨，太阳一天真的只出来八个小时。我总是确保在接下来的两三个月里、在夏天的日子里计划点什么，让我有真正期待的事情。这就像是隧道尽头的一束光，提醒我生活并不枯燥，只是天气冷，只是冰冻，只是我很难过。而且以后还会有更多时间为自己创造那些有趣的时刻和经历。我想谈谈最后四个建议。
have for this feeling, for getting out of this rut, the sense that life is boring. Number one, you need to get out of your sweatpants or your comfy clothes at least once a day. Now, I know this is hard, especially if you work from home a lot like I do, but what I was finding is that every day I kind of spent in the house, in my pajamas, never getting out for even the occasional walk or coffee with a friend or some sunshine, I just ended the day feeling a lot worse than the days that I did do those things. Just this simple act of getting up, putting on an outfit and leaving the house, it gives you just daily exposure to small things that are stimulating and interesting. Secondly, I would say yes to everything, even if you think it's going to make you uncomfortable
为了应对这种感觉，为了摆脱这种生活沉闷、乏味的感觉。第一点，你每天至少需要脱掉一次运动裤或舒适的衣服。我知道这很难得，尤其是像我一样经常在家工作的人，但我发现，如果我每天都在家里度过，穿着睡房里的睡衣，甚至连偶尔的散步、和朋友喝咖啡或晒太阳都没有，那么一整天结束时的感觉，会比做了这些事情的日子糟糕得多。仅仅是起床、穿上一套衣服然后出门这个简单的动作，就能让你每天接触到一些微小、充满刺激和有趣的事情。其次，我对一切都说“好”，即使你认为这会让你感到不舒服
or even if you think it's a little bit odd. Say yes to. you know, the party where you don't know anyone, to the work trip, to just new opportunities, because I think saying yes is a skill, and it also allows you to take action to make a change in your life to be more open to new experiences and to risks and to memories. Sometimes the easiest thing we can do is the most convenient, and the most convenient thing is to say no, but saying yes kind of says to the world, says to the universe, like I'm open to exciting things. I'm open to surprises. I'm kind of open to a challenge. Thirdly, do something for others. I know this feels like quite a strange antidote for boredom, but sometimes we really do need to
或者即使你觉得这有点奇怪。对……你知道的，去那个你谁也不认识的派对，去那次工作差旅，去迎接新的机会，因为我认为说是表达赞同是一种技能，它也让你能够采取行动，在生活中做出改变，对新的体验、风险和记忆更加开放。有时我们能做的最简单的事情就是最方便的事情，而最方便的事情就是说“不”，但说“好”有点像在向世界、向宇宙表明，我对令人兴奋的事物持开放态度。我对惊喜持开放态度。我有点准备好迎接挑战了。第三，为别人做点什么。我知道这听起来像是对无聊的一种相当奇怪的解药，但有时我们确实需要
get out of our own heads and realize that our lives are not the only ones that matter in this world, that we are sharing this planet with billions of others who could use a bit of help or some kindness. So pull yourself out of your own head for a bit, out of all your whole, thoughts and your boredom and direct your attention to someone else who might need it. I actually think that it is one of the most empowering things that you can do not just for yourself but for other people as well. And finally, declutter your space. Give that depression room a bit of a clean. Now I'm not going to sit here and tell you that this is going to magically give your life a whole new meaning and change everything. But I do think there is a correlation between how you keep your space
跳出自我狭隘的思维，意识到在这个世界上，我们的生活并不是唯一重要的，我们与数十亿其他人共享着这个星球，他们可能需要一点帮助或一些善意。所以，请暂时把注意力从自己的头脑中抽离出来，摆脱你所有的沉思和无聊，把你的注意力转向可能需要它的其他人。我实际上认为，这是你能做的最赋能的事情之一，不仅为你自己，也为其他人。最后，整理你的空间。把那个乱七八糟的房间好好打扫一下。现在，我不是坐在这里告诉你，这会神奇地赋予你的生活全新的意义并改变一切。但我确实认为，你如何保持你的空间与
and how you approach life. If you feel like your room or your home is in order, you are more inclined to want to be more productive or active in other areas of your life. And that is the really simple formula to overcoming a sense of being stuck or bored. You really just need to do more. You need to put yourself out there. And if you have a space that feels comfortable, you have a space that feels like it's organized and structured,
你如何对待生活之间存在着一种联系。如果你觉得你的房间或家井然有序，你会更倾向于在生活的其他领域变得更有成效或更活跃。这就是克服受困或无聊感的真正简单的公式。你真的只需要做得更多。你需要走出去。如果你有一个感觉舒适的空间，一个感觉井井有条、结构清晰的空间，
it's going to kind of inspire you to do more in your, you know, the external parts of your life as well. Do more with your life in any way that you can. Like I said before, I think we often fall into this trap of treating life like it's an inconvenience or something that we've been forced into because we don't recognize how precious it actually is to be alive and to be human and to love and explore and laugh and make mistakes and just do something impulsive every now and again. So if you have become trapped in a routine or a lifestyle that doesn't give you those moments of being like, yes, this is it, life is wonderful, I think it makes sense that you're feeling bored. And unfortunately, no one is going to
它会激励你在生活中……你知道的，在生活的外部部分也做得更多。以任何你能做的方式让你的生活更加丰富多彩。正如我之前所说，我认为我们经常陷入这样一种陷阱：把生活当作一种不便，或者当作某种我们被迫接受的东西，因为我们没有意识到活着、作为人类、去爱、去探索、去欢笑、去犯错以及偶尔做点冲动的事情实际上是多么珍贵。所以，如果你陷入了一种没有给你带来“就是这样，生活太美妙了”这种瞬间的常规或生活方式，我觉得你感到无聊是在情理之中的。不幸的是，没有人会
change that for you. You have a duty, a personal duty, to create the life that you want. And, you know, whether it's just a change in routine or environment. the people that you spend time with or just focusing on your mental health, you can really pull yourself out of this feeling, out of this period of boredom and just see kind of a whole new side to the world and how you want to choose to live it. So I'm sending you strength and love, but most of all, excitement. I hope that you enjoyed this episode. I hope that it left you feeling a little bit inspired or at least informed at the bare minimum. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, if you enjoy the psychology of your 20s.
为你改变这一点。你有一项责任，个人责任，去创造你想要的生活。而且，你知道的，无论是改变日常生活或环境，与你共度时光的人，还是仅仅关注你的心理健康，你都可以真正地让自己摆脱这种感觉，摆脱这段无聊的时期，看到世界全新的另一面以及你想如何选择生活。所以我向你们发送力量和爱，但最重要的是，兴奋。希望你喜欢这一期节目。我希望它能让你感到受到了一点启发，或者至少在最低限度上得到了启发。像往常一样，如果你喜欢这期节目，如果你喜欢你二十多岁的心理学。
Please feel free to give us a five-star review. Make sure you're following so you know when new episodes are coming out. If you have an episode suggestion or if you just have something that you want to say about this episode or any other episode, you can follow us at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram. And I am at Gemma Spegg on Instagram if you want to see some more behind the scenes content. Thanks again for listening today. As always, we will be back. next week with another episode.
请随时给我们五星好评。确保你已经关注，这样你就知道新节目什么时候会发布。如果你有节目建议，或者你对本期节目或其他任何节目有什么想说的，你可以在 Instagram 上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看更多幕后内容，我的 Instagram 是 @Gemma Spegg。再次感谢你今天的收听。像往常一样，我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO%，可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回看过去》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it, with our friends, fellow comedians,
从 1979 年开始，这对我是个重要的时刻。84 年对我来说也很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期，我们选择一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何在朋友、喜剧演员同行
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games.
和最喜欢的作家的陪伴下幸存下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。84 年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人克尔·加姆斯主持的《艰难学习》。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct?
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真正不安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士一起进行的。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。爱伦女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·兰日尼。我的大脑爆炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。这是一个 IHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是真人。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。